why you should learn how to run MySQL in
Google Cloud MySQL is a powerful and
versatile open source relational
database management system with this
power comes responsibility for managing
infrastructure sometimes it's easier to
hand that responsibility off to someone
else to be able to focus on more
important things like building your app
Q Cloud SQL a fully managed relational
database service for MySQL postgresql
and SQL server cloud SQL is kind of like
an account that you hire to do your
taxes so you don't have to it lets you
hand off mundane and time-consuming
tasks like backups updates replicas and
patches here's a tutorial where you can
enable Cloud SQL in a project create and
connect a MySQL instance create a
database upload data to it and query it
check out the pinned comment for a link
to the tutorial now you know